nos preguntan cuántas personas vez
veamos aquí hay una persona aquí hay
otra son dos aquí otra tres aquí cuatro
nada más veo 4 personas aquí así que
elijo el 4 comprobamos respuesta
es correcta veamos otro problema ahora
nos preguntan cuántas caras ves es una
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve diez caras ponemos aquí el 10 y
ahora comprobamos respuesta
es correcta veamos otro problema ahora
nos preguntan cuántas personas hay en la
barca vemos una dos tres aquí el que
está remando la mamá y el bebé son tres
personas comprobamos respuesta
es correcto hagamos un problema más nos
preguntan cuántas personas ves vaya
veamos tenemos una con cara de
sorprendida dos tres cuatro cinco seis
personas aunque si se fijan estoy viendo
estos dibujitos que es de una persona
pero es un dibujo no es una persona no
hay que confundirnos yo digo que son
seis personas comprobamos la respuesta y
es correcta
hagamos un último problema la cola del
tigre tiene rayas anaranjadas y blancas
cuantas rayas hay en total hay que
contar las rayas anaranjadas y las
blancas veamos la cola de este tigre
feroz
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 y 11 aquí ya
terminó la colita entonces cuántas rayas
hay en total 11 comprobamos respuestas
es correcta